I worked at Hooters I worked at Hooters
I worked in Hooters I worked at Hooters
hey let's get down to business how old
were you guys when you first applied 21
19 20 18 19 I was in college I'm looking
for body language how bubbly are they
hooter girls are typically pretty
outgoing outspoken did you guys all
start as hostesses no I started straight
in as a waitress okay don't you have to
be a Hostess first
yeah it's like it depends on your
experience I had hosting experience
previously like my location you have to
be a Hostess first like they don't hire
you as a server unless you've worked at
Hooters already how did you guys like
apply there there's like an open hire
and I just like showed up and had an
interview and got hired on the spot I
would just see it like constantly and
then I was just like okay well might as
well try Riley was kind of suspicious I
don't know it just sounded like she was
just making it up I really just wanted a
uniform so I kind of just was like let's
see what happens
mom was because a friend worked there
and she literally was like why don't you
just come with me and apply while I walk
in and I was like okay and then they
hired me the same day Hannah looks like
the ideal Hooter girl which is kind of
suss my sister worked there and then she
was like you should come work there and
I was like okay how did you start
working I was on a date yeah tutors I
had braces and everything I didn't know
what I was getting myself into and then
I was like yeah this is it
I don't know
if you like this episode and you want to
see more make sure to like this video
And subscribe to our Channel now let's
figure out who the mole is
[Music]
she was quieter in her body language was
just a little bit more reserved
she looks like a Hooter girl but she was
just quiet the whole entire time
I didn't expect to be out that early I'm
not gonna lie
um it was probably the piercings being
left in because piercings aren't allowed
everyone say Hooters makes you happy but
like really chippy
go ahead you start
Hooters makes you happy
okay I don't think I've ever said that
phrase but Hooters makes you happy
Hooters makes you happy
Hooters Makes You Happy Foods makes you
happy okay how about
um we all follow up with the next line
of the birthday song yeah okay so
Hooters has a birthday song food it says
Birthday song Not Too Short not too long
I I don't I don't think I know that one
I know a different one oh yeah our
Hooters taught us a different one how
did yours go
good thing is we sing for free yeah it's
a bad thing is we stay off key yeah
okay I'll sing it right and get your
wishes sing it wrong and do the dishes
yeah
so what's the what was your song though
I didn't start like that it was
um so it would come out and we would be
like okay there's a birthday in the
house and then we would start off with
try to remember how we started off
has a birthday song Not Too Short not
too long not too short not it is it's
the same thing I guess yeah she didn't
know the birthday song and then she said
she learned a different one but then
didn't know the second one either so
that threw me off too
um okay I have a question for you guys
what is one way to upsell I would just
sit in the booth with my customers bring
out whatever it was whether it was like
the you know desserts or like the
calendar I'd be like you could buy this
for me oh they love that oh they love
that they were like for you I'll buy it
I don't want it for myself but for the
desserts I would be like oh I really
like this flavor and they'll be like
okay get one and I'll get one for myself
I'd be like this is my the key lime pie
thing yeah I'd be like oh I get a chance
man on my break like I'll get some of
this oh you should get it too though
because we could share for real Yeah
Yeah you mentioned key lime pie what are
the other desserts caramel fudge cheese
honestly y'all it's been a long time
it's been so long I also was just
um she was kind of just like stumbling
on her words and I was like hmm she just
doesn't remember or she truly wasn't a
Hooter girl and just like doesn't know
what to say what's your favorite food on
there I liked the buffalo chicken salad
yeah I like the buffalo chicken
quesadilla okay favorite sauces
Daytona
[Music]
[Applause]
I was thinking like I have this in the
bag like there's no way anyone's gonna
vote me out so I don't know if you think
the mole is still in the box and you
like to continue playing the game please
raise your hand
so you're working at Hooters while
you're in college right yeah when I was
there that's what was it I didn't tell
my parents or anything too because I
don't know how they feel about it but
were you paying for college too yeah I
mean I went when I was in undergrad my
whole family knew I didn't care at all I
was trying to make money and it was fine
Hooters for me was more like a sorority
honestly like I love all the girls that
worked there I still keep in touch with
them yeah I've met a lot of my best
friends there actually like I'm still
really close with a lot of the Hooters
okay what is a blue moon served with
orange what about the Daiquiri
um oh I was never a server though I was
a food Runner Cherry yes
I would like I would like know the ones
that like my mom's got before but like
that's what I'm gonna say that your
mom's got before there my moms are
lesbian they love Hooters but I thought
your parents didn't know yeah they don't
no no I'm there no no I mean like before
like I've gone to Hooters with them
they've never come no way but they love
you but they wouldn't no they wouldn't
want you working wait were you no my
parents are strict about me but not them
you know what I'm saying like I know
because because they're like this is
gonna sound bad but like they're
sexualizing them so I don't think they
want me to be sexualized I don't know I
feel like your story is a little
suspicious I understand
I think all of us were kind of ganging
up on Hannah because we were just a
little bit suspicious part of me really
wanted to believe that she was a Hooter
girl she was selling it but then they
were just some things where I was like I
don't think so okay how do you guys say
how do you greet a guest when you come
into Hooters okay I'll just be like hi
welcome to hers how's it going guys hi
welcome to Hooters
hi welcome to who yes I do you guys all
did this I'd be like hi welcome to
Hooters you have to have a sweet
customer service for us yeah you fake it
but I mean you're entertaining I think
we're actually hired as entertainers we
are hired as entertainers because you're
not really allowed to like hire on a
server and then have requirements about
XYZ but as an Entertainer you're allowed
to have those requirements did you guys
take pictures with people and stuff like
that all the time all the little kids
all birthdays I know I know the little
like little boys are always in there
with their Dads yeah
for that though than like the creepy old
guys
like whatever okay really quick what are
the nail regulations and what's
happening can you get short and then
they could either be nude colors only
say one text I'm so sorry okay well I'll
say it I guess the next option is a
shade of pink yes but it cannot be a hot
pink it has to be a neutral yeah skin
color almost what about hair down they
want it down and done what color natural
color yeah natural color they don't want
anything bright those are good
what do you guys all do now so I'm in
sales I'm a sales representative and I
also teach kids how to play chess
I work in the Cannabis industry slash
bartender slash promo modeling I'm a
physical therapist I have my doctorate
degree no big deal
scooter girls are smart too yeah hooter
girls are smart I work at Sephora now
okay I'm like oh I'm trying I'm like I
almost believe you
I just wonder what lie did you tell your
parents that you were doing for work
like I only worked there for three
months and I only worked
why'd you quit trust me because um I
needed to make more money and they
weren't opening me up the server why
didn't they bump you up the server I
don't know maybe
I don't know I mean I'm gonna be honest
maybe my height
if you were tall it was better because
you would get more like front cover like
promo like stuff I like almost
wonderfully
Lots
[Music]
[Applause]
sorry girl your story just didn't match
up I'm sorry
I think the mole is still in the box and
you'd like to continue playing the game
please raise your hand
that means the game is over
if the lights turn green that means you
have voted out the mole and you all went
the lights turn red that means the mole
is still in the box and you lose
three
two
one
[Applause]
oh my gosh I felt it I felt it I felt it
I was like okay this is totally like a
Hooter yeah yeah it was totally a Hooter
Vibe on the count of three can the mole
please step forward
three
to
one
no
oh my gosh thank you
no you had us I you had yeah you were
close though yeah you were selling it
you're selling I watched like a lot of
the day in the life YouTube videos of
the hooter girls so I worked with um an
ex Hooters employee she made me like a
whole like study document we went over
that we practiced the birthday song we
were sitting there clapping singing to
it
yeah
my moms would not be okay with that okay
they definitely would not my parents go
but they don't they would not they did
not like me yeah so when she said that
you guys are suspicious I'm like oh my
God
I hid it from my parents for a while but
they literally couldn't have cared less
yeah honestly who the girls come in all
sizes shapes and you don't have to be
like the prettiest or the skinniest like
honestly Hooters will bring like the
best out of you it's just any other job
they're just pretty girls using their
looks to an advantage
um clearly not excessive Advantage but
it's literally just like going to any
other restaurant it's just that we look
hotter and then the worst part is when
you tell someone you work like worked or
work at Hooters like oh oh and that's
like what what do you mean what like
it's a family restaurant kids come for
their birthdays at my restaurant kids
eat free on Sunday so that was like the
specialty um I definitely think it's
actually sounds like a great job like it
seems very woman like LED I also noticed
they were talking about how you can get
guys kicked out easily that it really
seems like you're the focus of the
restaurant and that's really important
especially as a girl yeah there's like
this bad stigma around it but honestly I
feel like Hooters really molded me it
really empowered me and got me out of my
shell to become more of a girly girl
more confident and just really generate
like lifelong friendships
[Applause]
Hooters makes you happy